[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec à néry le
pallec bonjour vous êtes de la merde de
chevreuse je veux ce qu'ils célèbrent
évidemment pour son château de la
madeleine pour la vallée de chevreuse et
puis qui le siège évidemment du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse
vous êtes maire depuis 2010 est vous
avez été réélus aux dernières élections
municipales
alors quand on parle de chevreuse comme
ça on a évidemment l'impression d'une
qualité de vie de la forêt à côté du
parc de chevreuse
est ce que c'est ce que vous mettriez en
avant vous pour parler de votre ville
justement la qualité de vie bonjour
patrice oui quand on parle de chevaux je
pense que c'est notre notre principale
richesse savez ici on est dans un
territoire préservé qui en franges
urbaines bouquet vraiment tout près de
la zone très très dense est beaucoup
plus économique de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais on a aussi la chance d'avoir des
paysages qui sont remarquables des
espaces naturels qui couvre 80% de notre
territoire et je pense que c'est
vraiment ce que les gens ont envie de
voir envie de trouver bien de chercher à
chevreuse c'est ce cadre de vie c'est
cette cette ville à la campagne on va
dire et c'est quelque chose qu'on
s'attache vraiment de toutes nos forces
à à entretenir et préserver justement
qui sont les habitants de chevaux ont
applaudi les chevrotins c'est bien ça en
dit les chiens bretagne surtout les
chevrotine
il échoue bottines vous êtes chevrotine
qui guideront les habitants d'où venait
ce que est ce que c'est des gens qui
vivent et qui travaillent pour la
plupart à chevreuse ce que c'est des
gens qui travaillent un peu ailleurs sur
le territoire des yvelines peut-être
peut-être à paris d'ailleurs
alors si on regarde un petit peu dans
l'histoire sont remontées des centaines
d'années en a l'air mais dans l'espoir
de choses on est à l'origine une zone
très agricoles et maraîchères
donc chevreuse c'était de la culture et
de l'élevage bien sûr grandes mutations
au cours du 20e siècle
ces dernières années c'est surtout des
gens qui vont travailler vers saclay
personnes quentin et vers paris puisque
nos deux débouchés de la vallée sont
bien sûr saint quentin en yvelines et
parle du rer b également toute la vallée
d'yvette saclay et qui après paris et
puis je pense que progressivement dans
les nouvelles mutations auxquelles on
assiste là depuis très récemment qu'ils
sont accélérées pendant ces périodes de
confinement on a aussi bon pour les
catégories de socio professionnelles
pour lesquelles c'est possible une un
gros développement du télétravail
les professions libérales aussi alors
avec des gros besoins d'équipement par
exemple le très haut débit par exemple
des choses comme ça mais mais c'est
quelque chose qui va vraiment se
développant puisque pour nous aller
aller à paris matin c'est qu'un 20 km
mais c'était c'est une heure une heure
voire une heure et demie de route
donc voilà chacun essaye d'adapter
d'adapter son métier d'adapter ses
usages professionnels en fonction de ses
contraintes à et je pense que donc le
l'étape suivante ce sera de revenir de
diminuer certains trajets et de revenir
à des activités qui permettent de rester
sur place le plus possible alors on
parle évidemment de cette histoire
plutôt plutôt agricole est-ce qu'il ya
quand même des entreprises qui goûtent à
à chevreuse dans votre dans votre ville
alors le fleuron mois industrielle de
notre commune a fallu fraude le froment
le fleuron pardon et connaître de notre
commune c'est la savak la société de de
transport l'autocar qui emplissent une
société familiale qui a vraiment son
histoire à chevreuse c'était la fin de
la ligne de saut quand autrefois là les
premiers les premiers que ce qui est
devenu maintenant le rer s'arrêter à sow
cette ligne de car a été créé au xxème
siècle pour pouvoir emmener les
parisiens dans des lieux de villégiature
beaucoup plus naturelle on va dire que
le paysage urbain de la région
parisienne
c'est une société qui qui aujourd'hui
existe toujours et toujours géré par la
famille malheureusement après ça
effectivement on n'est plus dans des
petites entreprises des petites
structures et le tissu économique est
quand même pas du tout comparable à ce
que l'on peut trouver sur 50 alors je
reviens un petit peu sur votre
réélection en 2020 puisque vous êtes
maire depuis 2010 est je le rappeler
elle a été très serrée l'élection a été
contestée eu un premier jugement on est
en appel
on verra ce que de ce que ce que dit le
conseil d'état mais côte voilà on est un
maire dont l'élection est contestée est
ce qu'on peut quand même
gouverner prendre des décisions mais
être pleinement le maire de sa ville
vous avez les habitants et les
territoires doivent pas pâtir de cette
situation là donc on peut pas je pense
se permettre de rester dans des
situations de blocage pendant une durée
qui dépendrait de la justice donc oui on
peut tout à fait avancer on a la
légitimité qui est tout à fait reconnu
par les textes donc on a mis en route
déjà un certain nombre de choses et puis
normalement ce que fait un élu les gars
mais rien n'est irréversible on va dire
donc quel que soit le résultat le
résultat de la procédure et la décision
qui sera prise est ce qu'il y aura une
nouvelle élection s qui en aura pas dans
tous les cas je pense qu'on peut pas se
permettre pour des communes comme les
nôtres de rester un an voire plus dans
une situation d'attenté il faut que les
choses avancent et je compte la
situation de ces derniers mois a montré
aussi que les élus de terrain avait
vraiment un rôle à jouer et qu'on peut
pas juste attendre que les choses se
décident il faut continuer de toute
façon a avancé ne serait ce que pour les
habitants apprennent au petit grief
politique entre nous ce germond mais
pour les habitants faut continuer à
avancer
en tout cas ben vous le disiez c'était
un peu
la commune de cheveux c'est un peu de
communes d'avenir c'est à dire que c'est
évidemment ce doux rêve beaucoup de
français c'est à dire des communes à
taille humaine où la qualité de vie est
primordial c'est qu'elles sont si vous
avez un projet vous pour cheuvreux c'est
lequel moi j'aimerais bien que je
regarde cet aspect tradition cet aspect
ancrée dans l'histoire ancré dans son
architecture si si particulière dans cet
esprit nature et qu'en même temps elle
soit complètement tourné vers l'avenir
ce soit une ville comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure un petit peu de nouvelles
technologies qui fasse sans vie une
ville qui garde son charme son âme et
tournée vers l'avenir
voilà je crois que c'est ce grand écart
qu'il faut réussir à faire et sur lequel
on a déjà beaucoup travaillé et on
continue à avancer d'un beau travail
merci beaucoup à la mairie le pallec je
le rappelle qu' maire demers de
chevreuse merci beaucoup je vous en prie
a noté